revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 jueves ya estamos ya
finalizando casi la semana a rosa vamos
abrir entonces nuestra sección con
investigación de berlín cat
desentrañando el asesinato de sir en abu
l
buenos días raúl exactamente no
recordemos es irina bucle de la
periodista palestina estadounidense que
fue asesinada el pasado 11 de mayo en
cisjordania mientras cubría una redada
del ejército israelí en el campo de
refugiados de jenín bien recordamos que
los testigos que estaban con ella otros
periodistas sobre todo pues señalaron
directamente a las fuerzas israelíes
como responsables de este asesinato
incluso dijeron que ellos en tanto que
periodistas fueron objetivo directo del
ataque mientras que las autoridades de
tel aviv insinuaron a que podría venir
el ataque por parte de fuego palestino y
en todo caso ya las primeras
deliberaciones internas preliminares de
las autoridades de israel han planteado
dos escenarios pero tal y como señalaba
el incap dos escenarios en que en ambos
casos se trataría de muerte accidental
entonces qué hace el inca ttc recoge
todos los vídeos que han circulado por
las redes sociales de los momentos
previos y posteriores a este asesinato y
sacan algunas conclusiones dicen si bien
no podemos constatar a través de estas
informaciones pues al tienes la de quien
proviene la autoría no de este asesinato
sí que se puede contrastar pues con las
versiones que han dado unos y otros en
primer lugar vamos a intentar resumir
porque el análisis es extenso pues cogen
y determinan cuáles fueron las
posiciones las geolocalización es de los
distintos actores no implicados en ese
escenario esa mañana de mayo y bien como
lo hacen por ejemplo raúl cogen y ven en
los vídeos pues las sombras no para
establecer que realmente todos los
hechos que se ven en los vídeos que
circularon por las redes sociales
tuvieron lugar sobre las seis y media de
la mañana entonces recordemos por un
lado cogen el vídeo que circuló
ampliamente en el que se veía el cuerpo
de shirín tumbado en el suelo y sus
compañeros como intentan acceder ya a su
cuerpo mientras que las balas se lo
impiden por otro lado cogen también
vídeos que es que circularon sobre con
donde se ven hombres armados no y que
las fuerzas israelís usaron como para
decir que los saque las balas podrían
haber venido pues por parte de estos
combatientes y al final con la
triangulación ante las distintas
posiciones acaba nadando con este mapa
que vemos aquí y en el punto rojo
tenemos pues a donde cayó muerta digamos
sitting en el punto verde vemos dónde
estaban las fuerzas israelís y en el
lila y el amarillo donde estaban a los
combatientes palestinos y esta calle que
se ve entre el punto rojo y el punto
verde es la calle que hemos visto en
tantos vídeos desde donde provenían las
balas por otro lado también hacen un
análisis del sonido y es que en los
vídeos en los que se muestran los tiros
por parte de los combatientes palestinos
se oyen ráfagas de tiros mientras que
las balas
que suenan mientras los compañeros de
jilín intentan acceder al cuerpo dice
son tiros precisos no y por otro lado
también en base al análisis de sonido
establecen que en base al tipo de arma
que se ve en los vídeos al calibre de
las balas que estas armas disparan y a
la velocidad que habrían ido estas balas
establecen que los disparos provenían de
una distancia entre 177 y 184 metros lo
que pues se corresponde con la distancia
a la que se encuentran pues las fuerzas
israelíes respecto al punto donde fue
asesinada sería así es ross ambos
cónyuges current que publica las voces
de escritores palestinos que recuerdan a
esta legendaria periodista erin apoyarle
pero entre otras cosas lamentan que la
asesinato de shirín y quede reducido a
la procedencia de una bala no
exactamente y son a tres autores
palestinos los que escriben esta pieza
pero nos hemos quedado con el relato de
tarek va con iu y él dice la bala una
sola bala la bala fue disparada por un
rifle israelí o un rifle palestino esto
es a lo que se reduce todo todos los
demás detalles se han desvanecido atrás
quedó por ejemplo el hecho de que este
territorio ha estado ocupado más tiempo
del que ceiling vivió dice
independientemente de la procedencia de
esta única bala shirín fue asesinada por
un régimen de apartheid celosamente
comprometido con la supremacía judía y
la eliminación de todo lo palestino
shirín desafío la violencia implacable
diaria y a veces banal del régimen al
dar voz a aquellos a quienes el
apartheid israelí se empeñaba en
silenciar a su vez ella se convirtió en
la voz de nuestra generación y por eso
su voz tuvo que ser silenciada así es
rosa y cerramos esta revista de prensa
para ahondar incluso más sobre este tema
que acabamos de hablar con nuestro
primer invitado del día también con
usted aquí en el estudio pero vamos
entonces con un reportaje mirelis hay
los menores de casa quedaron
traumatizados un año después de los
bombardeos israelíes exacto husseini en
gaza- digamos recoge los testigos de
varios menores
palestinos que pues recuerdan y están
traumatizados como decías por la
ofensiva la ofensiva los bombardeos
israelís que tuvieron lugar ahora hace
un año y que como recuerda esta pieza
dejaron 256 muertos incluidos 66 niños
en gaza mientras que los cohetes
lanzados desde el enclave causaron a 13
y muertes en israel y por ejemplo pues
se cita a sus y espontánea y a su padre
que fueron los únicos sobre sus
sobrevivientes de un ataque aéreo que
devastó su casa la niña dice lo que más
me asusta es la muerte tengo miedo de
que mi papá muera una niña de 8 años no
y su padre explica que en las semanas
posteriores a estos bombardeos la niña
páselo pues sea muchos días sin poder
hablar tras pasar 11 horas de bajo los
escombros rozas gracias por esta revista
de prensa que ese conmigo para conversar
como ya lo adelantamos con él su primer
invitado del día